Now finally, since we have these last two linear factors, we can write f of x
as the product of four linear factors, which we knew it would have because it
is a function of degree 4. So now we can write that f of x equals x times 2 x
minus 1 times x minus 3 minus 2 i times x minus 3 plus 2 i. This is really
awesome. We've made so much progress since we started off. Now I have one final
question for you, and it's really what we've been working toward for the entire
problem. What are all the zeros of f of x? We already know two of them from a
couple of quizzes ago, 3 plus 2 i, and 3 minus 2 i. And so I'd just like you to
fill in the last two. Check in with the linear factors we haven't used yet to
find zeros, but at least haven't used in this quiz yet.